cruella gets things done stella does not
we always thought she just hated dogs
turns out there's much more to the story
disney's cruella has brought
so much information to light offering
really interesting contrasts and
similarities to prior iterations
it seems the origin of the dramatic
phrase the native dog
has been discovered we also get to see a
much deeper relationship between jasper
and cruella
as opposed to just the boss and henchmen
let's have a look
so let's begin there's a new cruella in
town
so let's check out the cruellas from
throughout the ages
the original of course was betty lou
gerson voicing this animated villain in
1961
as i know i know then there was glenn
close
the cruel of 1996 accidents will happen
and finally emma stone cruella 2021
i'm cruella the cruella laugh
is pretty similar in every iteration
each a dramatic and aristocratic feeling
cackle
the makeup has also stayed pretty true
to form throughout each version
the bold red lip and fabulously unique
black and white hair
are essential markers for the super
villain one difference we did see in
this version is that cruella was missing
her signature long cigarette holder
disney has a ban on smoking in their
films so it didn't make an appearance
something stone said actually made
getting into character more difficult
we've always known cruella to be a dog
hater especially considering her track
record of
dog napping and wanting to skin dogs to
make coats from their fur
in every version before this one she was
eager to make a coat from the uniquely
spotted fur of the dogs
yet here she wasn't quite there only
joking about committing the heinous act
the tables really are turned in this
version as when we first see the
dalmatians
we can actually understand why cruella
wouldn't be such a fan of them
they terrified her as a child and were
the reason that she lost her foster
mother
what we see in cruella is a woman who
actually loves dogs
especially her sweet companion buddy
who's been by your side from the
beginning
as for the dalmatians themselves they
seem to be a fan of cruella
so if we're trusting their instincts she
isn't a dog hater
at all while the relationship between
the villains and dogs
isn't the negative one we've always seen
cruella does still arrange a dalmatian
dog napping with horus and jasper as she
has in the other versions
if i'm going to need to repeat myself a
lot this isn't going to work out
anyone recognize this call anita
darling how about this one the native
doll
what's ironic about this version is that
anita's last name
is actually darling in the 2021 live
action
we see a far more fleshed-out and
interesting character in anita than ever
before
her relationship with cruella is also
much more positive than in the animated
version and the first live action
the origin story of their relationship
definitely helps us understand
why she would have wound up for working
for her in the future
as for roger well their feelings for
each other are
pretty much the same as in any other
version cruella and roger just
aren't the biggest fans of each other
and never really were
and it's a pleasure mr bill what's a
pleasure it does seem as though roger
has been practicing his cruella tunes
for quite some time as we see in this
mid-credits scene
definitely a bit of deja vu here
it wouldn't be the story of cruella
without dalmatians
but in the 2021 version we don't
initially get the lovable pongo and
perdita from previous iterations
these aggressive and fierce dogs are far
from these dalmatians we've come to know
and love from 1961 and 96.
while the dogs don't love her in 101
dalmatians
they're actually pretty obedient near
the end of cruella as we can see
pongo and perdita aren't the lead dogs
like they were in the other movies
they do still play a role in the 2021
live action when we see them meeting
roger and anita for the first time
setting up the 101 dalmatians story
perfectly
although we do still have some questions
about how
pongo and predita might be related
one thing every version of the story has
in common is that there was never an
actual coat made out of dalmatians and
thank goodness
in the first live action we get these
coat designs and then
in cruella a fully realized dalmatian
coat
it's pretty jarring initially especially
as the baroness realizes what's happened
she killed my dogs fortunately she was
wrong in this case
we do hear cruella joke about making a
dalmatian fur coat in the latest
iteration
but she does assure it's only a joke for
now at least
since it definitely foreshadows the
future that she heads to
i've got a few ideas the jasper and
horus duo we see in cruella are one of
the biggest differences between the 2021
live action and every other iteration of
the story that we've seen
how could we forget the bumbling type
henchman from the 1961 animated version
i know either either either
and the faithful duo in the 1996 live
action
morning man sit
this time around the pair remains
faithful to cruella but not without
question
at one point we even see horus and
jasper choose to reject cruella
until she reminds them that they are a
family
we definitely get to see more of an
equal dynamic instead of the boss enter
henchman relationship
especially with the origins of their
relationship when jasper and horus were
actually the ones who took cruella in
when they were all children the jasper
and cruella relationship
is one we definitely have never seen
before
audiences can absolutely ship them in
this movie
something we never would have thought in
the animated version or the 1996 live
action
one thing we can be sure of after seeing
cruella's early days is that she has
never been a good driver we do hear her
fully admit her experience with driving
didn't know you have to drive i don't
what we're wondering now is if since she
fared well enough
early on she might not have ever
bothered actually learning how to drive
since in these similar scenes it doesn't
look like her skills have improved
at all she really should probably just
be kept off of the roads
we've always known the story of cruella
to be associated with dalmatians
but in the 2021 live action they aren't
the primary pups
we get to see a spotlight on wink and
buddy two new dogs of the story
while the dalmatians are the ones taking
the lead and being their humans best
mates in every other version
we get to see buddy and tiny wink
playing major roles in pulling heists
and in wink's case modeling a rat suit
perfectly
one of the most exciting and strongest
similarities between cruella in every
version
is her incredible fashion talent and
skill while they are humble beginnings
it's pretty obvious from the get-go that
she's a force to be reckoned with
while her label hasn't been established
yet in the 2021 version
we do get a hint from the baroness that
it is indeed in her future
one great similar view we get between
the 1996 live-action and 2021 live
action
are the peaks at cruella's fashion
designs on view for all of us to admire
cruella's talent is evident in every era
considering the fact that the 2021
cruella is an origin story
it's no surprise we get a lot of
differences between this and earlier
versions we've seen but the similarities
are still there
what's really interesting is that
director craig gillespie actually didn't
go through other versions of the story
what does remain the same in each
version is that the story is set in
london
we love seeing this landscape whether
it's live action or animated
this time around we get very different
vibes considering cruella is set in the
70s punk era
whereas the animated version is a much
tamer world in the late 50s
the 2021 live action is also the first
time that the era it was set in had a
really strong effect on the characters
we absolutely adore this new version and
of course
emma stone's take on the iconic cruella
while this iteration is very different
from every other time we've seen
this story we still get to revisit
classic moments like maniacal driving
and dog napping
what was your favorite moment from the
latest disney flick